- When I found out
I was hired by Hala
to be part of this project,
I was really excited
and was really looking
forward to working with her
and hearing from her perspective
and contributing my part
to this project.
I think it's a great opportunity
that Radcliffe has brought
us to be able to work together
and for me to have this chance
to know Hala who's a
leading expert in her field.
This exposure is really
a chance that I wouldn't
be able to get elsewhere.
I'm really grateful for it.
- Research Partnership
Program at Radcliffe
is excellent simply because
I am a strong advocate
for mentoring.
Mentoring young generation,
bright generations.
This is my second term
here at Radcliffe.
I enjoyed very much working
with the previous partners,
we already have
a paper published
on merging biology
and engineering,
and now we're working
with Linh on introducing
the concept of 3D printing
to the materials we
are working with for
orthopedic applications.
If you have a
defect in your bone,
you would replace
that with a metal.
Metal has never
really been designed
to be part of our body.
So why would we need to
replace the use of metal?
And this is what I'm
working on, something
that would replace
the use of metal
and becomes part of our body.
Linh's application stood out
because of her experience
in evolution biology.
I recall when I read her
application that there was
osteosarcoma in it, but that's
not what really attracted me
to Linh's.
And when she walked into my
office she was on crutches
and that's when I'm
going, oh my goodness,
that's the one
with osteosarcoma,
which is cancer of the bones.
And I looked at Linh and she
had these long surgical marks
on her tibia and
femur and that's
when I thought it could not have
been a better match of having
Linh working on the material.
- As Hala already mentioned,
I had osteosarcoma
when I was 10, which is
a form of bone cancer.
There was an extra
growth in the bone
and the doctor had
to do an operation
to remove that section
of bone and that
leaves the question of what
could be put in to that gap.
What they did back
then in 2006 was
to get bone from a bone bank
and substitute it into the gap
where my original bone was taken
out and putting a metal plate
to hold everything together.
There were many complications
with that original bone graft
because it was not my own bone.
So there were
problems with healing
and various complication with
the metal parts coming apart.
I've had to go through
a lot of surgeries.
10 surgeries in total
over the past 10 years,
since I was first diagnosed
with osteosarcoma.
I felt that Hala's project is
really meaningful in the sense
that it negates the need
for metal for patients
that have bone defects.
- I'm hoping for this
medical technology
to reach to the patient
as close as 2019
and we're very,
very close to that.
Having a research
partner at Radcliffe,
it goes well beyond research.
You form this
bonding relationship
with these young rising stars.
I still communicate with
my ex-Radcliffe partners.
They email me, update
me on their progress,
and if they need mentorship
I'm always there for them.
And I hope it will be the
case with Linh as well.